Magnus strikes first after that initial
draw but it's almost a a double question
mark because you could have done better
not because Bishop f for itself was so
bad Rook e seven oh he car forgot
goodness he Caro forgot that Rook takes
E8 is going to pin the queen he drops a
miner piece yeah at first I was like
wait a minute Bishop A6 is he forgetting
there's a queen on F1 but then it was a
step further than that he knew the queen
was there but Magnus Rook takes E7 and
Rook takes E8 he is going to pull away
with a victory here especially with 10
seconds left on the clock for hikaro
after this plunder and he resigns
because A6 Falls you can't take the
queen and